rappelez-nous ce qui s'est passé
exactement quels sont les derniers faits
dont on dispose
après cette attaque qui visait les
catholiques
bonjour pour le moment il ya une
nouvelle qui vient de tomber
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué
mais aussi une attaque à avignon au
couteau avec un assaillant qui étaient
abattus par la police sans leur europe 1
avoir crié à la hauteur donc c'est cette
pourrait s'agir d'une attaque coordonnée
seulement deux heures à la précédente
je joue simplement pour pour revenir sur
sur cette information qui est surtout le
fait de nos confrères d'europe 1 selon
nos confrères du parisien cette fois ci
concernant
l'assaillant qui a été arrêté ce matin à
nice il est âgé d'une trentaine d'années
il est à l'hôpital après avoir été
blessé et il aurait déclaré aux
enquêteurs avoir agi seul
ils revendiquent les faits mais il
aurait donc agi seul le lien avec
avignon dont vous me parlez pour
l'instant à prendre avec beaucoup de
pincettes ce je vous laisse continuer
sur sur les faits alors ce matin année
s'il était il était donc aux alentours
de 9 heures oui bien entendu on peut
aussi le lier aux informations qui sont
sortis ce week-end un appel au jihad
individuel de la part d'une agence liés
à al qaïda sa peine tabbat il ya eu d
une communication de gérald darmanin que
du lit dgpn envers les préfets et les
policiers ce qui était craint à ce
moment là c'était que des personnes
soient appelés à intervenir de façon
individuelle avec des armes blanches des
voitures béliers donc que des armes par
destination
on voit que c'est ce qui vient de se
produire à deux heures d'intervalle 3 2
heures 3 heures d'intervalle sur le
territoire français dans des zones pas
très éloignées l'une de l'autre
les premières informations font état
d'un homme de type nord-africain d'une
trentaine d'années il concerne l'attaqué
niçoise qui a été blessé lors de
l'intervention de la police municipale à
première vue
j'ai pu échanger avec le sec le
président du syndicat national de la
police municipale qui est justement
policière municipale à nice
il a rappelé qu'à son sens cela
soulignait la nécessité pour les
policiers municipaux d'être correctement
armés d'armes létales pour pour les cas
où elles sont de plus en plus appelés
est repris - carrément sur les sur les
attaques telles que celles d'aujourd'hui
alors là ça ira donc était interpellé
dans la foulée le centre ville a été
sécurisé la ville de nice qui dispose
d'un système de vidéo surveillance vidéo
visiblement ça n'est pas suffisant en
tout cas pour prévenir ce genre d'actes
alors la ville d'anissa et des villes
tests de pilotes pour la vidéo
surveillance et la reconnaissance
faciale on peut le rap est pour le
moment effectivement cela démontre que
le système ne porte pas ses fruits
peut-être c'est quand même une fille qui
aimait beaucoup beaucoup qui a beaucoup
investi pour sa sécurité
ce sera la première vit probablement
avoir un commissariat de police
nationale qui sera joint celui de la
police municipale sur le même site d'ici
quelques années
c'est cengic qui s'inscrit dans lé ce
qui se fait de plus en avant garde du
point de vue de la du continuum de
sécurité et de la paix de ses qualités
du quotidien en france cependant on peut
se souvenir d'un des quatre attentats
qui skie été commis sur le sol français
en 2016 chez eux
dix jours seulement avant celui de
saint-etienne du rouvray qui rappellent
cruellement celui d'aujourd'hui
alors quelles mesures faut-il prendre qu
est ce que vous lisez sur le web puisque
vous êtes journaliste web pour nous
chères t france
qu'est ce qu'il ressort alors on se
parle à midi
qu est ce qui ressort beaucoup de
sidération sur sur twitter si c'est ça
que vous voulez ce que vous voulez dire
et puis des mots tels que celui tels que
ceux qui viennent d'être employé par
l'intervenant précédent c'est à dire
ceux qui ceux qui ont trait à la une
certaine guerre civile qui se
déroulerait sur le territoire des appels
au calme des appels à refuser la
division entre les français et bien sûr
on les lit aussi car peut-être une
certaine lassitude de la part des
français aussi sur sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est ce que en polymère en
direct la par exemple sur twitter
effectivement merci beaucoup d'avoir
était avec moi sur rt france